do you have anything to say about the
object shot down over Alaska Mr
President
success so President Biden reacting for
the first time after ordering the
Pentagon to shoot down a second high
altitude Airborne object flying near
Alaska just a few hours ago
on February 9 North American Aerospace
Defense command detected an object on
ground radar and further investigated
and identified the object using fighter
aircraft
the object was flying at an altitude of
forty thousand feet and posed a
reasonable threat to the safety of
Civilian flight we have no further
details about the object at this time
including any description of its
capabilities purpose or origin the
object was about the size of a small car
so not similar in size or shape to the
High Altitude surveillance balloon that
was taken down off the coast of South
Carolina so they're telling us it was
not manned or maneuverable the military
is trying to recover it now and there's
a chance that it came down on Ice the
White House pressed on why it was so
aggressive after letting China fly its
spy balloon All Over America
that's a really big area up there it's
not all that many planes it's not like
it was in the middle of the Northeast
Corridor or something in other words was
there some reason why president wasn't
willing to take that kind of a risk in
in time that because it because uh
um this thing did not appear to be
self-maneuvering and therefore at the
mercy of prevailing winds it was it was
much less predictable it's also strange
President Biden acted so quickly to
shoot this second object down but just
yesterday said that this about the
Chinese bibleone was
do you regret not having insisted on
bringing it down sooner no the total
amount of
intelligence Gatherings going on by
every country around the world is
overwhelming
judge I'm confused make it make sense
you can't make sense from this man I I
must tell you the tote no he's he
doesn't regret taking it not taking it
down sooner but I got to tell you I want
to move forward now and based on where
we are now Lawrence it appears that you
know we they they admitted that they had
this awareness Gap that they didn't
really analyze that section between I
think it's uh 60 and 100 000 feet where
these balloons are generally flying uh
and so now they apparently have a
standard operating procedure we know
they didn't have that procedure this
past week because they saw the Chinese
spycraft on the 28th and didn't tell the
white house until the 31st so there were
there was no standard operating
procedure and so now apparently we have
a plan we know what we've got to do the
White House has to be informed and I uh
Lawrence I was comfortable today with
the people that I heard after they said
they took this this smaller our balloon
down because it might get in the way of
civilian aircraft but the people that I
saw were competent generals who
understood who were fluid and and glib
with the with the facts and knew how to
communicate the president doesn't know
how to communicate I don't think he even
knows what's going on and I hate to say
that but the truth is now the American
people are aware of what's going on and
we're not going to tolerate it and Lisa
murkowski was Furious that it went over
her State and now what we've got is you
know China relations Biden's trying to
say oh no everything's fine until even
Judy Woodruff had to say to him but have
you spoken to him since he said no and
right now we know that General Austin's
counterpart in China would not accept
this call so we are not in a good place
right now and we've got China that wants
to be number one in the world militarily
economically and they see us as a threat
and sooner or later this is going to
happen and as long as we're on our game
I'm happy so Greg as someone who tells
jokes for a living is America looking
like a joke because whether that was
China or some other Nation it's obvious
that there are times in the U.S right
well here's the thing now we're just
going to shoot down everything oh we're
gonna shoot down like condors and
I don't know balloons Angels kites kites
that could have been the Goodyear blimp
heading to the Super Bowl but they said
here's the thing they said it was
dissimilar to a balloon that's this
recent object it's forty thousand feet
in the air it's the size of a car it's
not a plane it's not a drone it's
obviously an E.T super because nothing
on Earth fits that description so get
ready for the cover-up America they're
gonna say they're gonna say oh it turns
out it was like a weather device
no we know what we know what happens we
know what's going on and if I happen to
disappear over the weekend it wasn't a
suicide
trust me
Sandra Smith what are your sources
telling you uh in the intelligence
community and the defensive Department
because they acted much differently in
this situation I don't think any
American has criticizing them for uh
acting with with swiftness here the
question is why didn't they do it in the
other situations it might have been
perfect timing but I had a former
Defense secretary Mark esper on our two
o'clock at on with us in the two o'clock
hour when this was all Breaking we were
able to listen to John Kirby announce
this together and have him react right
out of it and my question was very
similar to judge jeanine's you go back
to that Judy Woodruff interview when he
was asked about our relations with China
especially after the state of the union
and his mention of China and whether or
not that it leads to a deteriorating
relationship with China and he said no
she asked him how he knows and he said
he just knows but shouldn't she be on
speed dial shouldn't someone in China be
picking up our phone call today asking
do you claim this object especially
after we just took one down from the sky
within the past week that doesn't seem
to be happening we cannot this is a UFO
this is an unidentified flying object I
mean very simply exactly we do not know
who claims this why why don't we have a
quick answer to that
um I will I will also just finish with
this how many more are out there right
and was this already in the air when the
other one was taken down was it sent out
after that I think there's huge
questions
um I don't know if we know any more
within hours days weeks I don't know if
there's is there a dozen more in the sky
right now we just don't know stinks I
tell you it stinks
the ribs
um Jessica the criticism of the
president has become quite bipartisan
and it looks like the threat of China
has become bipartisan as well with the
China committee it looks like all the
Democrats uh at least the Hawks are
coming on board with it do you think
that the president has the strength I
mean I know he has the mental capability
from being over the foreign relations
and understanding diplomacy but it looks
like this is a threat does he have that
defense background to defend the country
especially when you have people like
Robert Gates and other people that say
he can't make the call he never makes
the call
so it's not having General Petraeus as
your president or general McChrystal
right this is someone who hasn't served
but it is someone who has served in the
Senate like you said on the Foreign
Relations Committee he was the head of
it for a long time he has strong
relationships on the right and the left
with people who have served and after
the intelligence briefing yesterday
there were Republicans and Democratic
senators who emerged from that and said
that they think that it was handled
properly and there's a key difference
between what was going on here and the
judge you brought this up as well this
object was flying at 40 000 feet which
is where when we're in Planes we're at
36 000 feet right so there was potential
to actually go into an aircraft the
Chinese spy balloon was at sixty
thousand feet we our f-22s couldn't even
get there so there was a question of
what can we even do with this until it
dips down to a point where we could
reasonably take it down then on top of
it when the president was on Wednesday
said uh last week I take it down
chewed it down and they said we have to
wait until we can first of all safely
and we're going to have a better
recovery process if we do it over water
and they picked Myrtle Beach for this to
be the location of it and I know Jesse
took issue with the idea that our divers
are weak and they can't go in the cold
right the Waters of Alaska are colder
than South Carolina
Jesse when he's not here I'll text him
and tell him that I said it and uh
I know the point that you're trying to
make is that Joe Biden is weak and the
point I understand that he has a
diplomatic background but when it comes
to acting the defense keeping Americans
safe does he have that ability because
he may not be Robert Gates and neither
was President Obama at the time and
didn't sit on the foreign lace but he
knew how to go out there Osama Bin Laden
said he was wrong foreign policy
decision he ever made and we all sat
here in our proverbial seats at at that
stage in time and criticized Obama about
the red line in Syria right that he
didn't Assad one and gassed his people
and the idea was and Hillary Clinton
wanted to go in there and he pulled back
on that there has been criticism of
Obama and foreign policy and there will
be criticism of Joe Biden foreign policy
Afghanistan is the biggest example of
that but Joe Biden is the president who
the second the ukrainians needed help he
got in there he's also the only American
president who speaks out of turn about
defending Taiwan if China comes after
them that's not what she did
they didn't act soon enough
under the fire to get the weapons there
but if the president would have gave it
to them sooner I think that's the point
though he acts after the fact and we saw
that here as well even if I had hold up
an example of Joe Biden putting on
military gear
you would still be negative about him
you'll never see him doing that all
right well he's saying he's not supposed
to he's the president I think he should
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else